[Music]
hi my name is Nikolai and I'm going to
give you a quick start on how to get
started with immersive stream for XR and
the corresponding unreal template
project we will have a look at all the
assets the blueprints and the logic and
the level and this will hopefully give
you a quick start on how to kick off
your own projects
note that we will not be covering the
gcp stream API in this
tutorial be sure to check our knowledge
base for materials demos tutorials and
the full documentation that show
specific use cases and features in more
detail so let's kick it
off after downloading the template zip
file unpack it and move the new folder
into the unreal projects folder you can
also rename the folder and project file
if you like
if you already have unreal version 5.0
installed you are good to go if not go
back to the epic games launcher and
install unreal version 5.0 from there
now that you have your template project
unpacked and ready open it up in unreal
version
5.0 let's have a look at our level setup
in the levels window first as a general
approach in immersive stream for XR we
are using a main persistent level which
is called main
persistant and that is able to load
different streaming levels depending on
the use case if we have a look at the
folder structure in the content browser
here you can find a few descriptive
folders like blueprints global maps
movies St assets and UI and so
on let's start with the maps holder here
you can find all the relevant levels to
do your first tests by default Unreal
Engine opens the level main persistent
that holds three other levels that you
can see here the level 3D background
holds the background for the 3D mode and
contains an hdri backdrop and a
directional
light the AR background level is used
when user is switching into the AR mode
it holds a static lighting setup with a
directional light a skylight a shadow
plane to receive shadows and a
postprocess
volume
the content start level is the place we
want to focus on for the beginning this
level gets loaded by default together
with a 3D background level when the
experience starts right now you only see
the cloud logo BP blueprint in there in
which we will have a look into in the
next
section in the blueprints folder you can
find all the relevant blueprints for
immersive stream for XR projects to work
most important is the XR init blueprint
where you can change for example the
default content level and much more in
the respective subfolders you can find
the other blueprints for example for the
a
mode in the UI folder you can find
blueprint widgets and other elements
that are user interface
related Global holds the global project
data like a interor collection the cube
map blueprints the controller and
more located in the St assets folder
there is the cloud logo BP blueprint in
there let's have a look into
that in the viewport of this blueprint
you can see a tool tip and a mesh with a
corresponding variable name to be able
to access it
programmatically in the event graph you
can see that there's already a touch
event handling implemented that is
changing the mesh from the solid one to
the transparent one and back and that's
triggering the visibility of the tool
tip
element the next blueprint we look into
is the XR init blueprint that you can
find in the blueprints folder if you
open it up you can see some logic being
executed in the event graph we're
running init commands loading Blueprints
and loading the initial levels in the
details window you can change basic
information like the start level for
example now let's talk about using your
own assets to get started with that you
need to import the assets to into
ideally new folder in the content
browser in my case I'm creating a new
folder called
custom I go into it then I hit the
import button on the top of the content
browser then I select my asset I import
everything and I wait until the import
is finished from there I go into the
content browser again move to the folder
maps and open up the content start map
because that's the map where your
content can be placed
easily here I can drag the asset into
the scene I can move it around scale it
rotate it as I need
it
previewing your project locally is very
easy to preview your project including
the system UI you can either simulate or
play the main persistant
map congratulations on working with your
first project with immersive stream for
EXA I hope you found the video useful
you can find all the relevant
information links and more resources in
the video descript deson I wish you a
great day see you soon and
bye